Many horror stories exist out there that stem from one common cause
manipulation
Even the word has a scary slimy tone to it, but have no fear psych2go-er
There are measures you can take to protect yourself. Here are 10 signs you're being manipulated
Number one, they constantly make you prove yourself
They never respect your boundaries and always ask for your love and attention
They are usually impatient demanding and selfish you often
Overextend yourself because you fear upsetting or letting them down
They never let you off the hook and guilt trip you into doing things for them. Even if it's inconvenient for your schedule
Two, they communicate passive-aggressively
Manipulators are rarely ever direct with their sly and cunning behavior. They prefer to communicate
Passive-aggressively and won't hesitate to talk about you behind your back
This protects their good guy or good girl image if they also turn to a middleman to communicate for them
This shows they are afraid to confront you personally
manipulators desire control which means they have a hard time facing their fears because it means letting go
Three, they Gaslight you gas lighting is a manipulative technique that makes you feel like you can't rely on your own memory anymore
When someone gas light's you they will pretend like they didn't say something that hurt you in the past
They will often twist the truth and reinvent it which makes you question your sanity
Gas lighting isn't just manipulative. It's a form of serious abuse that is dangerous
To learn more about it. Check out our video 10 gas lighting signs in an abusive relationship
Four
They're always just joking
It might seem harmless at first but manipulators can take their jokes too far that end up hurting you
When you stand up for yourself and confront them about it
They will try to brush it off and tell you that you're being too sensitive
Manipulators won't mind embarrassing you in public either
This gives them an audience and they're experts at getting others to laugh at you with their jokes
When you tell them to cut it out, they'll tell you that you're either making a scene or being a party pooper
Five
They play the victim card
when the two of you fight
Manipulators will always make you feel like it's your fault
They try to play the innocent victim who is badly hurt by your words and actions
Manipulators are experts at looking like helpless small creatures
They never believe they've done anything wrong as a result
You find yourself apologizing all the time because they avoid taking responsibility for their own mistakes
Six, they kill you with kindness
Manipulators will try to be the nice guy or nice girl and do favors for you that make you feel pressured to return them on
The surface they will buy you gifts or give you compliments
But then the next time you guys hang out, they might hint at wanting an expensive watch that's out of their budget in reality
They were only kind to you because they had other motives
Seven, they make your problems feel small
Manipulators always want the spotlight
If you ever complain about a bad day
You're having or all the difficult situations you're going through they will play the comparison game and minimize them by talking about their problems
For instance if you complain about a sunburn you got they might talk about the aches and pains they got from exercising
Manipulators do everything they can to get the attention they want even if it means buying your pity
Eight, they emphasize their calm cool and collected side if you express your anger and frustrations openly
Manipulators might keep calm just to make you feel like you're overreacting
This technique makes them feel superior over you because they know you look like you're being dramatic while they stay cool and detached
They will be dismissive of your emotions and often refuse to talk to you until you've sorted your feelings out
Nine, they use emotional blackmail
If they tell you that they will die or harm themselves if you leave or break up with them
Then they are trying to gain control by threatening to hurt themselves
this leaves you in a highly uncomfortable and unfair position where you feel obligated to stay against your own will
Not only is this toxic, but it risks their own health on the line
It's best to contact the police before things get out of hand
Ten, they take advantage of your trusting and sensitive nature
manipulators often target insecure sensitive and overly trusting
Individuals if you're usually told by others that you're too nice or tend to wear your heart on your sleeve
Take precaution and keep your vulnerability at bay
Manipulators are skillful at spotting people pleasers who often put their needs on hold to take care of others first
Initially, it might seem like they care about you when they give you attention but later down the road
They'll start to use you for their own benefits. It's their subtle way of luring you into their trap. So watch out
Do you think you're being manipulated, please share your thoughts with us below
Also, don't forget to subscribe for more content from sight to go and check out our patreon.
Thanks for Watching